[Musique]
depuis le samedi 3 décembre le musée
Lambinet situé à Versailles à rouvert
ses portes au public après des travaux
durant trois ans alors Émilie
Maisonneuve vous êtes la conservatrice
de ce musée qu'avez-vous fait comme
travaux qu'est-ce qui a été changé alors
on a changé un terme entièrement le
parcours c'est à dire que l'intégralité
des 35 salles et des trois niveaux ont
été repeints scénographie changer on a
complètement varié en fait le propos
voilà pour un propos beaucoup plus
lisible et puis on a édité un nouveau
guide des collections aussi et du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on peut découvrir ou
redécouvrir comme œuvre alors l'oeuvre
phare vous parlez tout à l'heure d'un
luthier qui travaille pour
Marie-Antoinette c'est une harpe qui a
été réalisée par le luthier justement de
Marie-Antoinette le luthier principal
donc en fait c'est une harpe du 18e
siècle des années
1786-87 et qui en fait une sorte de
prototype avec 8 pédales et la
particularité c'est qu'on l'a restauré
pour pouvoir en jouer donc on fera des
concerts privilégier de temps en temps
avec cette harpe qui a un son très très
particulier et qui vraiment redonne vie
à ce 18ème siècle qu'on illustre très
bien au musée l'embêté et également des
peintures des sculptures c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué parce
qu'en fait on est un musée de
collectionneur donc le principe c'est
que des donateurs depuis le 19e siècle
en fait on fait le choix de donner leurs
œuvres au musée en Binet donnés ou légué
donc on a un ensemble très varié en
effet en termes de beaux-arts qui va du
16ème siècle au 19e siècle pour la
partie principale on a aussi des
éléments du 20e siècle mais un petit peu
moins courant et donc en fait on
présente de manière beaucoup plus
organisée avec les peintures 18e
peinture 19e les objets d'art qu'on a
vraiment remis en valeur ça c'était
vraiment notre propos principal c'était
de ne plus les montrer comme des faire
valoir mais vraiment comme des oeuvres à
part entière et dans une scénographie
beaucoup plus théâtrale aussi
qu'auparavant et donc ce musée n'existe
depuis
90 ans en quoi en fait c'est un symbole
pour la pour la ville de Versailles ce
musée on est vraiment en effet le musée
d'art et d'histoire de la ville de
Versailles donc pour beaucoup de
Français voilà ils connaissent le rôle
de Versailles durant l'Ancien Régime et
on a été aussi à des moments importants
de l'histoire la Révolution les années
lisseurs sont dix une ville majeure en
fait dans l'histoire de France donc
notre notre propos est de parler de
l'histoire de la ville mais liée à
l'histoire de France et puis de montrer
justement la richesse des artistes et
artisans qui ont travaillé pour pour la
ville tout particulièrement pendant
l'installation de la Cour dans notre
dans notre ville Grégory vous aviez une
question peut-être une certaine forme
d'impatience pendant ces trois ans de
travaux c'était important pour peut-être
lui donner 90 ans de plus tout ce qu'on
peut lui souhaiter au musée Lambinet
même davantage on travaille un peu pour
pour l'éternité parce qu'on est un musée
musée de France donc toutes les œuvres
faites qui sont dans notre dans notre
inventaire dans notre fond font partie
du patrimoine de condamnation donc c'est
notre rôle de les conserver en effet
trois ans c'était long mais on a eu
aussi la période covid qui finalement
était pour nous une opportunité en fait
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans les
travaux et puis aujourd'hui on est très
très heureux évidemment de retrouver de
retrouver le public enfant Nicolas
comment vous articulez aussi avec le
château de Versailles forcément les on
peut imaginer les touristes qui viennent
de l'étranger pensent directement à
aller au château de Versailles comment
vous travaillez avec le château de
Versailles pour peut-être aussi venir
découvrir votre musée à vous et les
oeuvres que vous avez alors en fait on a
des des échanges avec eux on leur prête
des oeuvres ils nous prennent des œuvres
on a des oeuvres en dépôt d'ailleurs qui
qui sont accepté de déposer pour le
nouveau musée et puis l'idée c'est en
fait d'être plutôt axé nous sur une
visite
conviviale une visite aussi dans un
certain confort le château de Versailles
c'est beaucoup une visite de célébration
il faut absolument avoir vu le château
de Versailles et nous on va chercher
plutôt à tirer un public familial un
public francilien et puis un public
actif parce qu'on va souhaite mener des
visites un peu particulières des visites
relaxation
œnologie voilà pour essayer un petit peu
de d'attirer ce public actif qu'on
espère avoir en soirée et le week-end et
donc cette année vous allez fêter vos 90
ans est-ce que vous avez préparé quelque
chose vous avez prévu quelque chose
alors on a fait en fait souffler les
bougies au musée au mois de juin alors
quand c'était encore fermé mais l'idée
en effet c'est de pouvoir utiliser cette
première année pour lancer toute une
nouvelle programmation des événements
des visites théâtralisées et je pense
qu'à l'occasion essentiellement de la
Nuit des Musées prochaine donc ce sera
en 2023 ce sera l'idée voilà de marquer
le coup à nouveau pour célébrer un peu
en retard cette anniversaire donc une
programmation qu'on pourra connaître
prochainement oui alors on a tout un
système de communication avec évidemment
les réseaux sociaux on est très actif
sur sur les réseaux et donc vous pouvez
suivre toutes toutes les nouvelles
propositions qui sont faites pour tous
les âges et pour toutes les populations
et bien merci beaucoup Emilie
Maisonneuve d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et d'être venu un plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes la conservatrice
du musée l'embinet situé à Versailles et
si vous ne savez pas quoi faire ce
week-end vous pouvez découvrir ou
redécouvrir ce musée ce week-end
peut-être et quelque chose me dit que si
vous êtes aussi à court d'idées Gabriel
vous avez prévu des idées de sortie pour
noter les spectateurs et oui tout à fait
Mathilde on commence avec l'événement de
ce weekend pour les fans de sport
l'équipe de France affronte l'Angleterre
samedi soir pour les quarts de finale de
Coupe du monde alors la ville de Poissy
propose la diffusion du match sur écran
géant au forum Armand Peugeot à la clé
de cette rencontre une place en
demi-finale vous le savez rendez vous
donc à 20h pour le coup d'envoi et
plutôt dans la journée le Maroc
affrontera le Portugal alors on sait que
vous êtes nombreux dans les Yvelines à
soutenir ces deux équipes on vous attend
en Story sur notre compte Instagram et
Facebook TV 78 pour un petit sondage
qu'on vous a préparé pour se connaître
l'équipe que vous supportez alors à 18h
sachez que 75 64% de nos abonnés
supporter le Maroc et 36 le Portugal je
sais pas autour de la table du Portugais
sont nombreux à la communauté portugaise
et nombreuse partout même dans les
Yvelines donc ils ont intérêts aller
mettre les supportent le Portugal il
faut égaliser et puis en plus le gagnant
de ce match affrontera peut-être
l'équipe de France il qualifie contre
l'Angleterre
vous avez
plus culturel oui jusqu'à samedi soir de
20h30 à 22h30 le théâtre montentier de
Versailles propose la pièce petit pays
alors cette pièce elle est inspirée du
roman éponyme de Gael Faye elle retrace
l'histoire d'un Bourdin dont l'entrée
dans l'adolescence est marqué par le
début du génocide des Tutsi au Rwanda
pays voisins on assiste au passage de
l'insouciance de l'enfance à la prise de
conscience de l'adolescence parmi les
thématiques qui seront abordées dans
cette pièce on parlera de l'histoire
coloniale le racisme mais aussi le
partage des frontières qui a été imposée
au peuple africain et on reste dans les
sorties culturelles puisque vous nous
avez sélectionné une exposition à
Clairefontaine oui si vous avez envie de
vous réchauffer un peu et de voyager je
vous conseille l'exposition plein feu
elle est dédiée à l'ambiguïté de l'astre
solaire c'est une exposition lumineuse
et colorée qui nous interroge sur notre
rapport au monde engageant une réflexion
sur nos modes de vie notamment alors
vous avez jusqu'à dimanche pour en
ensuite il y aura une pause et
l'exposition reprendra le 7 janvier 2023
et ce jusqu'au 29 janvier les vacances
de Noël approchent à grands pas et c'est
le dernier week-end pour profiter du
Noël décalé à la Commanderie oui toute
la journée la commanderie de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines vous propose
un moment festif parmi toutes les choses
à faire vous pourrez profiter d'un
marché d'associations solidaire et de
créateurs locaux vous pourrez également
profiter d'activité de création et ou
encore de déguster des spécialités on
sait que vous aimez ça vous avez
tendance à aimer ça autour de la table
des spécialités afro caribé
donc
que serait ces fêtes de fin d'année sans
patinoire Gabriel oui vous pourrez
patiner à Élancourt Maisons-Laffitte ou
Maurepas carrière sous Poissy ne fait
pas exception le village de Noël
et t'accompagner d'une piste de glisse
vous pourrez en profiter jusqu'au 30
décembre
on peut faire un petit tour de table
est-ce que vous avez une sortie que vous
avez pris
[Musique]
François Angleterre je pense oui
forcément il y a le football on est tous
les deux grandes fun de sport 22 sport
22 sport avant tout et oui forcément les
quarts de finale de cette Coupe du Monde
nous attire mais j'ai toujours pas fait
mes cadeaux de Noël donc pourquoi pas
aller faire un petit tour à la
Commanderie
[Musique]
et si vous souhaitez continuer dans
cette ambiance de Noël il y a toujours
les marchés de Noël dans les Yvelines
qui sont en cours on commence à plaisir
les festivités auront lieu au Parc du
Château et ceux des vendredi soir et
l'encours organise également son
événement pendant 3 jours sur le parvis
de l'Hôtel de Ville a Guyancourt ce sera
un marché solidaire pour la ville
jumelée de Comé au Bénin rendez-vous à
la Maison de l'environnement pour le
marché de Noël de Magny-les-Hameaux et à
la place des justes pour celui de
Saint-Cyr l'école à Maurepas est au
gymnase de La malmedonne que vous
pourrez profiter de plusieurs animations
dès vendredi soir à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux le marché de Noël
se tiendra au Centre sportif les
pyramides et pour la semaine prochaine
ce sont les communes des clés sous bois
et de Trappes qui installeront leur
marché de Noël pour les clés sous bois
rendez vous à l'espace Philippe Noiret
pour trap le marché se tiendra à toute
la semaine du 16 au 23 décembre sur la
place de la Merise et d'ici là les fêtes
de fin d'année il est possible pour les
petits les Yvelines noires mais aussi
pour tout court de déposer leurs lettres
au Père Noël Nicolas est-ce que vous
avez déposé votre lettre
la mairie d'épônes à ma lettre donc
j'espère que la mairie d'épaule
l'enverra comme il se doit au Papa Noël
pour les autres communes plusieurs
plusieurs boîtes aux lettres sont à
disposition n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner sur le site Internet de la
mairie à Plaisir la boîte aux lettres
est situé dans le parc de l'Hôtel de
Ville à Maurepas sur la place Charles de
Gaulle pour maniller les hameau aller
dans le hall de l'Hôtel de Ville a
Guyancourt la boîte est installée sur le
parvis de l'Hôtel de Ville attention
postez bien votre lettre avant le 15
décembre pour Poissy c'est sur la place
de la République à Rambouillet le lien
avec le Pôle Nord restera établi
jusqu'au 24 décembre la boîte aux
lettres permettra au rambolitain de
déposer également des cartes ou des
dessins qui seront ensuite distribués
aux personnes âgées attention à bien
indiquer sur vos lettres Père Noël pôle
Nord ainsi que votre adresse pour avoir
une réponse et comme d'habitude le jeudi
Nicolas d'André vous nous avez préparer
un petit quiz c'est sûr qu'elle t'aime
cette semaine on va parler des espaces
commerciaux puisque vous savez le papa
noël est en train de parcourir ces
espaces commerciaux des Yvelines et
parcours l'ensemble des centres
commerciaux et donc on va redécouvrir un
peu les centres commerciaux on va faire
un voyage dans le temps maintenant
depuis la semaine dernière on utilise
les archives donc je suis allé chercher
dans les archives première question nous
sommes le 6 décembre 2008 et regarder
cet extrait d'un reportage réalisé à
l'époque sur la pose d'une première
pierre regardez
une première pierre pour
si le chantier est déjà bien avancé ce
pôle commercial marquera une nouvelle
ère pour la ville connue surtout pour
ses magasins implantés anarchiquement le
long de la RN 10
excusez-moi pour le bip qui est parce
qu'il y avait la réponse forcément alors
à votre avis la
preuve concerne quel espace
comme tu es reconnu moi sur les images
l'ancien maire de Coignières en
ripailleux donc je dirais que c'est ta
Coignières et pourquoi pas
son commercial des portes de Chevreuse
réponse bravo Grégory la réponse va
s'afficher à l'écran effectivement les
portes de chevreuses à Coignières voilà
avec l'espace commercial des portes de
choses situées à côté du forum JB à côté
de Maurepas finalement et donc on sait
qu'il y a toute une réflexion
aujourd'hui sur l'avenir de ce pôle
commercial qui doit être réaménagé alors
deuxième question on va aller loin on
retourne au siècle dernier retour en
1999 je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage réalisé à l'époque sur le
centre commercial de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines regardez
bonjour
comment vous le trouvez ce centre
commercial
on fait les courses au chaud il y a tout
ce qu'il faut
c'est bien pour moi personnellement je
trouve toujours tout ce que j'ai besoin
donc ça va quoi
quelques soit votre âge vous êtes plutôt
satisfait de votre centre commercial
régional et pourtant depuis un mois des
travaux sur la Place Colbert annoncent
de profonde modification et l'arrivée de
nouvelles enseignes le développement
aujourd'hui des centres commerciaux
passe par effectivement une offre
commerciale
minimum des enseignes attractives mais
nous essayons de faire en sorte que les
centres commerciaux deviennent également
de des centres de loisirs des centres de
vie
car le centre souffre d'un péché
originel il est sous-dimensionné pour
répondre à sa vocation régionale d'où
l'idée de l'étendre et d'attirer des
enseignes attractives le magasin H&M et
sa mode chic et pas cher sont de
celle-là il devrait ouvrir d'ici la fin
de l'année l'escalier d'accès au centre
sera supprimé et l'entrée par les
escalators améliorer ce n'est que la
première tranche des travaux côté avenue
du centre l'hypermarché devrait être
agrandi en raie de rue d'ici quelques
mois autres projets derrière le théâtre
une extension dédiée aux loisirs avec un
grand complexe cinéma multissal autant
de moyens de renforcer l'offre
commerciale
alors à votre avis de quel projet parle
le journaliste de télé 78 de l'époque le
projet de la fin le projet de la fin mes
collègues
mais la médiathèque non
un projet d'espace de loisirs Skywest et
oui Grégory bravo c'est Skywest alors on
va voir la réponse s'afficher puis on va
commenter quand même ces images on voit
que l'avenue du centre finalement il n'y
a pas la grande enseigne de grandes
distribution il n'y a que le souterrain
il n'y avait pas l'espace à la surface
de l'avenue du centre tout est vide en
fait et finalement derrière
à côté du théâtre finalement il n'y
avait pas encore Skyway c'est pour ça
qu'on voyait cet espace vide parce que à
l'époque il n'y avait pas encore ben ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui Skywest
troisième question on poursuit donc le
quiz en 2012 avec ses nouvelles images
regardées réalisées à l'époque avec un
espace commercial assez végétalisé on
voit que c'est l'alpha marque 2
plusieurs centres commerciales assez
étendu alors est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire oui si tu es cette espèce
commerciale
[Musique]
bravo on va voir la réponse s'afficher
effectivement c'est au Clayes-sous-Bois
alors c'est vrai que c'était une
question assez simple mais on aurait pu
se trouver parce que c'est à la limite
avec plaisir donc on aurait pu aussi
avoir ce doute savoir si c'est plaisir
ou les clés sous bois on va passer à la
quatrième question regardez ces images
nous sommes au début des années 2000
alors c'est compliqué ou pas on va voir
il faut faire attention à l'ensemble des
détails à votre avis dans quel centre
commercial se déroule ces travaux qui
concernent un cinéma
regardez bien les images
ça ressemble à l'espace 50
Grégory encore une fois bon je sens que
Grégory va reconnaître effectivement bon
on va voir la réponse s'afficher c'est à
l'espace 50 ans et regardez bien les
images avant après c'est assez
impressionnant
[Musique]
voilà concernant ces images ça fait
plaisir quand même de voir ces images du
passé voir comment c'est aujourd'hui et
ça date que du début du siècle actuel a
inventé une siècle voilà alors question
de rapidité c'est assez simple
franchement le premier qu'il a là je
vous donne l'autorisation même si j'ai
pas posé la question vous pouvez y
répondre regardez ces images est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire dans quel centre
commercial on est ça a parlait de
Mathilde bon il y a même pas eu le temps
n'a pas eu le temps s'afficher on a et
bien réponse en images
centre commercial situé à au Chesnay au
Chesnay Rocancourt avec son copain et
son grand frère Vélizy 2 situé à Vélizy
2 allez dernière question un peu plus
compliqué celle-là regardez ces images
alors on a d'abord le centre commercial
mon grand mon beau Michelet pardon et
ensuite on va voir les images
du centre commercial mon grand plaisir
mais est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
alors c'est les deux centres commerciaux
qui sont sortis de terre c'est les deux
derniers est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quel est l'entreprise qui a l'initiative
de ces deux projets
merci à vous non ce n'est pas une
personne l'entreprise à l'initiative des
deux projets monuchelet mon grand
plaisir
[Musique]
je suis affiché dans les amis
est-ce qu'on peut remettre une vidéo
on va voir la réponse tout de suite le
point ne sera pas attribué sur cette
question la réponse tout de suite il
s'agit en fait de la compagnie de falsey
voilà donc à l'initiative de ces deux
projets de ces deux derniers centres
commerciaux qui sont sortis de terre
dans les Yvelines voilà bien merci
beaucoup Nicolas dandry à chaque quiz on
en apprend un peu plus sur l'histoire
des Yvelines merci
[Musique]